if you tuned in to the destiny
livestream earlier this morning then you
may be feeling some mixed emotions the
good news is that the update will bring
new gun customization taken weapons new
chroma lights and a collectable side of
taking armor with sweet jittery dance
moves in addition legendary year one
weapons are being brought up to
competitive damage levels in PvE the
desolate armor set Spectre armor set and
faction armor desolate armor and Specter
armor can be found in sterling treasure
boxes that can be earned through level
41 prison of elders the weekly crucible
challenge or hard earned cash money
silver you guessed it you can buy
sterling treasure boxes through
microtransactions thanks never verse the
armor sets will be level 3 when you find
them but this update also adds one to
one armor infusion to help you get up to
max level spotted in the new emotes were
an SNL dance a seinfeld dance a karate
kid dance and Shia LaBeouf just do it
action there's also a new ship available
called the waiting star in order to
accommodate all your new sweet loot
vault space has been increased to 108
slots so what do you think destiny fans
are you going to just do it Shia LaBeouf
style drop real currency on sterling
treasure boxes or take an intergalactic
pass on this one for more coverage of
destiny stay tuned to gamespot com
you